[Musique]
l'écho slide pour démarrer afin
d'illustrer le propos que je vais
essayer de vous faire rentrer dans le
coeur et dans les esprits aujourd'hui
pour sauter dicks pour démarrer ce tedx
j'aimerais vous proposé d'embarquer
si j'y arrive dans un voyage à travers
la prose de la nature la nature et le
vivant c'est une histoire qui à presque
4 milliards d'années qui se rappelle à
nous les humains par des petits instants
quotidien d'émerveillement simple pot
éthique esthétique comme la sensation
s'allonger dans un champ simplement et
observer les fleurs percevoir
l'esthétique il nous est transmise d'une
ingéniosité qui revient depuis 3 8
milliards d'années
exactement ce que la nature a bien fait
pour commencer ce voyage je vais essayer
de vous amener d'abord par le souffle
des vents ou celui d'un enfant sur les
aigrettes d'un pissenlit ce végétal je
les observais et volets pendant des
heures et des heures et encore
aujourd'hui ce végétal anodin aux yeux
du plébéien vous le retrouvez absolument
partout il se propage par les vents
grain nomades d'une symphonie bien
orchestrée par la nature se pissenlit
gelé cueilli mille fois du bout des
doigts et la petite scène blanche qui
s'écoule de ce puissant lille c'est du
latex du latex naturel qui sort du
pissenlit du latex qui pourrait nous
être utile pour remplacer des milliers
produits de notre quotidien qui eux sont
peut-être aux sources et part du
caoutchouc naturel avec une ressource
renouvelable et locale à latex naturel
qui pourrait nous permettre de faire des
préservatifs sans perturbateurs
endocriniens ou de faire des gants de
chirurgie non allergènes pour continuer
ce voyage je vais vous amener toujours
un peu plus loin là où les animaux
peuvent nous surprendre et nous
émerveiller jusque dans les endroits au
style de notre planète la nature a
toujours trouvé un moyen d'adaptation
pour la vie et d'innovation il ya
environ 300 millions d'années donc bien
avant nous les
humains les premiers scorpions
apparaissait sur terre à l'époque du
carbonifère ça s'appelle comme ça parce
qu en europe de l'ouest
des tonnes de charbon se sont accumulés
dans les sols et pendant que nous nous
avons utilisé ce charbon pour produire
de l'énergie et parfois de la pollution
cette petite bête
le scorpion elle a continué à passer
sous nos yeux pour nous aspirer le
scorpion lui dans ce milieu hostile
résiste à des très hautes températures
la journée des températures basses la
nuit il résiste à l'abrasion du sable
grâce à son exosquelette on pourrait
s'inspirer de son exosquelette pour
construire des habitats qui résistent à
ces mêmes problématiques de hautes
températures et de basses températures
sans utiliser de machines sans utiliser
d'énergies fossiles ce scorpion
finalement son exosquelette c'est un peu
un cocktail entre de la chitine c'est
une matière marrante
on en a beaucoup dans les cheveux de la
craie des choses dont sont faits les
coquillages c'est un peu son cocktail
d'exosquelette qui lui permet de
résister à ces conditions extrêmes
si on copiait la forme et la matière de
l'exosquelette du scorpion on pourrait
faire des abris pour les réfugiés en
zones arides avec une exigence
écologique élevé et une forme d'habitat
souhaitable et sain à l'intérieur la
nature tous les jours je mens ecstasy
des fois sur des choses qui dépassent la
capacité qu'on a de voir avec nos
propres yeux le monde de l'infiniment
petit les bactéries les bactéries sont
présentes absolument partout sur notre
planète
elles composent la grande partie de la
biomasse elles sont à l'origine de la
vie à plus 3 milliards d'années par
exemple dans un gramme de sol
c'est-à-dire en gros une cuillère à café
vous avez 10 millions de cellules
bactériennes dans une gouttelette d'eau
1 litre vous avez un million de cellules
bactériennes
est ce qu'il ya de marrant avec ces
bactéries quand vous les cultiver dans
un bac chez vous une sorte de
fermentation de thé en symbiose avec des
levures et bien vous pouvez obtenir
obtenir vos textiles de demain vos
vêtements qui pousse une fibre celluloïd
qui se développe tout seul que vous
pouvez travailler ça ressemble un peu à
du cuir produire des vêtements non
polluants sans énergie et dur dégradable
pour pouvoir réinvestir le capital
naturel tout ça avec des petites
bactéries
et comme ces bactéries sont un peu
merveilleuse et qu'on les observe de
plus en plus et ben on peut aussi
étudier la manière dont l autre
mise les flux d'informations de matière
et d'énergie pour produire les solutions
de la ville intelligente
un thème qui revient beaucoup en ce
moment afin d'attaquer les
problématiques d'architecturé des
réseaux d'énergie de mobilité de santé
de nutrition et de haute technologie
ces bactéries qui sont présentes partout
sur la planète on les connaît pas très
bien en fait on marche souvent dessus
quand on se balade
elles sont contenues lansol alors si on
prenait ces bactéries et qu'on les
mettait dans une colonne transparente
d'un mètre de haut directement devant
les yeux des humains ont un tas serait
sept couches différentes de terre et à
l'intérieur de ces couches il y aurait
des microbiome bactérien qui interagir
est entre eux avec de l'énergie de la
matière de l'information et si on
utilisait cette matière et cette énergie
produite par les biomes bactérien dans
la terre à l'intérieur cette colonne
sous les yeux des humains
ensuite pour éclairer je ne sais pas des
bandes de l'aide par exemple dans un
jardin public on créerait un médium
poétique pour que nous les humains nous
puissions dialoguer interagir
directement avec ces bactéries
si en plus on utilise cet objet
technologique bactérien avec une
technologie celle là très humaine pour
échanger des contrats pair à pair de
manière open source et des entre
décentralisée sur l'énergie ou sur
l'étude scientifique des bactéries là ça
commencerait à être complètement dingue
pourquoi faire ça c'est assez simple de
ces travailler avec le vivant et de le
comprendre et d'en faire des objets
d'interrogation pour nous les humains la
première chose c'est donner un médium
d'expression à ces bactéries à nos
propres yeux
simplement parce que on aime que ce
qu'on connaît et on ne protège que ce
que l'on aime donc on a besoin de
connaître les bactéries une autre raison
de ce type de médium poétique avec les
bactéries seraient de sa culture et nous
les humains avec une nouvelle
technologie émergente est de permettre
de traiter les questions sociétales
qu'elle pose en gros à l'ère du
numérique la question pour nous les
humains c'est savoir coder ou être codé
utilisé cette colonne de winogradsky
pour les plus scientifiques pleut gay
avec une technologie humaine
décentralisée open source pourrait nous
permettre de développer les briques d'un
système énergétique décentralisé et
autonome en fait à travers cette
question de la poésie de la nature que
je vous propose dans ce voyage dispose
une question société pouvons nous
changer les paradigmes de notre monde
tout en préservant ses ressources
qui parmi vous n'a jamais rêvé d'être
explorateurs ou exploratrice d'un monde
lointain par exemple un désert au centre
de l'australie ou simplement une forêt
près de chez soi
observez les nouvelles manières de
d'innover par la nature avoir un
dialogue poétique avec des objets
d'interrogation copier les matières à
travers les exemples que je vous ai
donné les formes et les systèmes de la
nature s'inspirait du vivant ça
s'appelle le biomimétisme innover par la
voie du biomimétisme s'inspirer du
vivant pour faire des systèmes plus
frugaux qui réinvestissent dans le
capital naturel qui préserve la
biodiversité qui répondent à nos défis
sociétaux d'alimentation d'énergie de
mobilité de nous les humains
finalement le biomimétisme ça peut être
très utile au quotidien dans les
applications technologiques dans
l'alimentaire dans beaucoup de choses
mais la question ça nous pose plus loin
c'est la question des ressources
finalement des ressources à gérer c'est
ce qu'ont pour faire ça pour gérer ses
ressources cet environnement nous avons
les biens communs les communs les
exemples des communs sont la
biodiversité l'eau l'air la connaissance
les savoirs mais les communs ce n'est
pas juste un ensemble de ressources est
un ensemble de ressources plus une
communauté qui alimente et qu'ils
partagent et qui entretiennent ces
communs c'est un système
socio-économique un nouveau paradigme
social de coproduction et de co-création
le fait de gérer un bien commun comme on
gère à bien privé mène à sa destruction
c'est éric hardin garrett hardin pardon
qu'il l'a souligné pour faire ça pour
gérer ses biens communs et faire du
biomimétisme gecko créer un à cloud de
biomimétisme un laboratoire citoyens de
prototypage de solutions open source
inspiré par la nature à l'intérieur du
cas il ya une communauté d'acteurs libre
qui entretiennent
c'est bien commun ces ressources
matérielles et immatérielles on pratique
de manière libre le code informatique le
design l'architecturé la botanique la
philosophie et plein d'autres matières
finalement notre légitimité de faire
elle se fonde justement sur le faire la
personne qui fait est légitime avait
écrit michel lallement pour faire
marcher ses projets pour développer ce
lab pour entretenir ces communs il m'est
arrivé parfois de dormir à la rue sous
des ponts parfois sans danger en début
d'année j'ai même tout plaquer pendant
quatre mois j'ai plaqué mon activité
professionnelle ou mes activités
professionnelles plutôt mon appartement
j'ai mis toute ma vie dans un sac à dos
j'ai pris mon ordinateur et je suis
parti pendant un peu plus de quatre mois
dans un tour de france en omettant au
service d'autres projets open source
dans les communs alors finalement
innover c'est beau protéger la nature
c'est très important mais faire tout ça
ça parle forcément de force et de
volonté
je peux bien être créateurs de start-up
intervenant dans une grande école mentor
professeur à l'université je peux bien
faire du consulting pour les grandes
entreprises
mais ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance
et ça n'aura aucune valeur si je suis
privé de la chose simple et poétique de
m'allonger simplement dans un champ et
d'observer les fleurs autour
je crois que nous avons besoin d'aimer
la nature par notre émerveillement
quotidien pour en faire un bien commun
de l'humanité
je suis persuadé que nous avons besoin
d'écrire notre poésie avec les petites
choses de notre quotidien
écrire notre poésie avec la nature pour
construire un monde désirable soutenable
et durable
[Musique]